estamos en las redes sociales
Hoy es el día más importante Río de
Janeiro para Los amantes de la Samba y
del carnaval porque en esos momentos los
jueces deciden Quién es el campeón del
carnaval estamos en Vila Isabel una de
las escuelas de samba favoritas que ha
sorprendido el sapódromo no solo por la
temática dedicada a las fiestas de
Brasil sino por llevar temas polémicos
como la integranza religiosa y Incluso
el poliamor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no
es alegría dolor chistosos
[Música]
hay Emperatriz
una de las favoritas no campeona pero
todavía hay una posibilidad de
conquistar el tercer lugar y aquí las
personas Todavía están
emocionadísimas
[Música]
que la escuela no ganaba y por eso había
mucha esperanza pero no esta
vez perder y a pesar de la marca derrota
se alegran por la victoria de sus
vecinos la Emperatriz León continente